let me begin by focusing a little bit on
our host country France France is now a
member of a select global leaders in the
European fiber of the home community and
it has risen to this common position
because its leaders in its industry saw
the advantages of fiber in the home
earlier than most because there was a
vision of what can be achieved with the
kind of capacity that only fiber can
deliver because there was recognition of
how important will be for France to be
amongst the world digital leaders as we
approach the third decade of this
century because France knows that her
children will need this fiber foundation
in order to be able to compete
successfully on a global digital stage
the leadership demonstrated by France
and others have helped to ensure that
this vision is seeping into the European
Commission the Commission's recent
gigabit society communication makes a
strong start towards setting a new
vision a vision where we have very
widespread very high capacity networks
and they underpin the services to
society that will keep Europe at the
forefront of economic development
globally we've made huge progress and
moving forward however there is more to
do which brings me to the points that
I'd like to touch on today firstly what
is our vision as part of the home
council for Europe for the future why
this part with the right infrastructure
to achieve that vision and where are we
made progress and what do we need to do
next let me begin with our vision many
of the potential uses of fiber to the
whole will have significant impacts on
society foundational to digital
innovation fiber based societies will be
equipped to deal with the inevitable
future growth challenges
and other world becomes increasingly
digital and as our population construct
continues to age for me fiber the whole
table put the deep fiber that will be
needed to deliver on the gigabit society
that Europe is aspiring for is not about
of generic Internet connectivity instead
it's about laying the foundation for
Europe's children to be able to compete
on a level playing field with their
global peers it's about removing the
barriers to digital innovation so Europe
can be positioned at the forefront of
the world's digital societies it's about
ensuring that Europe has the necessary
infrastructure to permit its industries
to take a leading position in the
emerging arenas of 5g autonomous
vehicles IOT Smart Grid and more
importantly all the future digital
industries that we haven't yet imagined
they need that future proof
infrastructure for me this is about
building the bootstrap that will be
needed to kick-start Europe's economy
and ensure that we do not get relegated
to becoming the digital impoverished of
this third decade of this millennium
fiber the home infrastructures are
betting clusion they are about the
removal of barriers they are about
ensuring that our future innovators are
not restricted by the capabilities of
infrastructure from the last century
it's about ensuring our innovators are
free free to create the next Google or
Amazon's comfortable in the knowledge
that their national infrastructure can
scale to meet the needs that they don't
have to serve as a global economy fiber
the home infrastructures will facilitate
the transition of digital workers to
home working environments and will
ensure that the application of
telemedicine and care will have a
profound impact on how our aging
societies function in the future in the
case of home working this will bring
many benefits including
ability for fiber rich communities to
retain their best and brightest rather
than suffer the continuity of
traditional brain drain to the large
cities throughout the world and this has
direct positive impacts ranging from
positive GDP growth in the region's to
increases in property prices to relief
in traffic congestion in our cities and
towns while in parallel allowing those
that are faced with long commutes to
clawback increasingly scarce personal
time while we all reduce our personal
impact on the environment in the case of
home-based he held applications d
congestion over already overstretched
health care facilities along with
substantial financial savings to the
state can be anticipated however the
largest benefits will be for the users
of these new telemedicine and telecare
services permitted to remain safely
within their community for much longer
as a productive member of society
quality of life will be substantially
improved for all in parallel the
duration of time spent in elderly care
facilities per individual can be greatly
reduced easing the burden on already
existing creeping resources while in
many cases providing greater
preservation of personal wealth in so
many fiber rich examples the benefit
accruing to society goes far beyond the
direct economic benefits invested are
identified by the investor community as
one of the main recipients society in
general will be the main beneficiary of
the fiber networks being built to this
end it is critical critically important
that society's understanding of these
benefits is increased and that society
starts to demand change if I look at the
mid to long term challenges facing
Europe over the both the challenges of
our aging population
and the increased pressure that they
place on our health care systems
environmental sustainability and lifting
economic productivity must be core to
all government strategies
fiber-to-the-home networks can help to
deliver or enable a significant part of
the solution to each of these challenges
part of the home infrastructure is the
capacity to transform public services
like education and government services
but it relies on the enablement of the
right infrastructure to deliver the
appropriate services the public sector
is the perfect tenant for such networks
but it needs to use its power its power
to help move the market and it can only
do that by committing to the change that
is needed changes that are needed to
raise educational standards while
simultaneously increasing the
availability and reducing the cost of a
world-class education for all of
Europe's citizens changes needed to
offset the cost increases driven by our
aging population while simultaneously
improving the quality of life for our
elder citizens
changes needed to eradicate the barriers
to innovation by our digital natives so
that Europe could take lead a leadership
role in the world's digital future this
will involve significant that serious
change it is complex and will require
negotiations across all facets of
society whether it's with teaching staff
and their unions nursing and medical
staff and their unions it won't happen
overnight however we have started and we
have started well we were only at the
beginning of possible developments that
can be enabled by fiber capacity most
future applications we cannot even dream
of today history has been consistent
history has shown us that the bandwidth
always precedes the application
innovation think about doing everything
we take for granted today like Netflix
and FaceTime or Facebook blogs do
another one megabit connection let's see
how you get on or better again do it on
a dial-up connection the reality is that
the experience would be so poor that we
would never use those applications let
alone the billions of users that enjoy
them today the bandwidth have to come
first a fun fact to think about in any
given City the traffic that you will see
will typically consist of approximately
30% of cars that are looking for a
parking space it's a fairly simple
example forewarned liquid have a great
impact on mobility and cities connected
cars will be great in themselves but
imagine the possibilities with traffic
management when the cloud is the
capability to detect congestion building
in a city and to slow down traffic from
entering that region similarly